let's bring in a John Calipari the
Kentucky head coach coach let me start
with that tough question would you
rather be five feet tall or seven feet
tall and no athleticism whatsoever what
are you guys talking about it was a slow
day yes nothing going on yeah are you
trying to get viewers or taste people
way I think we're just doing this for
our self coach if people want to
eavesdrop they want to you know watch or
listen that's up to them so this is more
for you yeah we just have fun memory
remember you would tell your kids just
go out there and have fun
that's why I'm just saying it's not
about winning don't we all win if we're
having fun coach okay would you rather
be a 5 foot or 7 footer with no
athleticism I'd rather be like that
7-foot guy that walks in and nominates
yeah I don't know I what is it that's
like would you run real fast if it's
pitch dark if you do a wall was in front
of you would you do that then try to win
the race wait what kind of question is
when you're questioning my question oh
and you just gave me that question and
you it both questions are like we have
nothing to do this is a conversation
this is like a Seinfeld nothing ok let's
start over and let's welcome in John
Calipari the Kentucky head basketball
coach who joins us from New York City hi
coach how are you what what do people
say in New York when they see what's the
general question that you get
most of them looking like call me by the
wrong name or don't even know or their
heads down and it's I love this city
this is a great city there everybody you
know when you know there this is
give me a lading place to think about
three days really yes it is did the
Knicks ever call you to coach no no they
didn't and Scott Perry and our friends
and it's going to do a great job Steve
Mills we've talked about the draft and
different things but now and you know
the biggest thing I got a great job I
mean I'm in the great situation and I
think these teams know that and you know
the teams that I talk to mostly about my
players you know and if anybody talks to
me more than that it's you know going
back and forth you know like hey what
are you doing and I was really happy for
Dwayne Casey well this Arella
you know what I mean the job he did in
Toronto you know being in Boots right
now I mean having a team that you know
could be able to say their personnel
there they got a chance so happy for the
best player you coached against the
shoes who Jesus I'm not I don't think
about those guys more or less worried
about my guys well I know but i i'm
curious your opinion when united tell me
who play it Sexton is pretty good right
yes he's really good he's really
physical got some size what though you
know physically ready he's good good
player when's the last time you actually
watched a player against your team like
you were entertained by watching a
player he was that good you ever allow
yourself to do that no never
and if a guy goes crazy I'm bad that I
didn't double to let's do something like
why would I let this guy do this and
I've had I've done that a couple of
times I did won't believe this at time
to get hard-headed and I'm not gonna see
we're not playing about someone we're
not traffic someone gotta guard him not
you know and I'm not a hard-headed kind
of guy you know what's the next level up
some hard-headed what would that be
are you defiant no that's not a good
word come on man I mean you used to be
look this is this is called slipping
how about discovered how about to see
wanna be seriously stubborn would have
been pretty good with hard-headed yeah
okay
stubborn bet someone slipped your
network how about a watch how about
Italian southern Italian from Calabria
that's what it is yeah how many how many
your kids are going first round I'm
hoping three or four but what you have
is Kevin Knox you know that position
list with the leaders going through six
nine almost six ten the only 18 years
old youngest player in the draft
you know scores it suits it che
Alexander six point guard with
seven-foot wingspan that means switch
pick and rolls you can play in pick the
roll the ball you too you know freshmen
you have Hamid Diallo the best athlete
in the entire draft you have tarik
Vanderbilt who only played 14 games for
us but his analytic numbers were off the
team so they're all calling me like what
does this mean and then when you Gabriel
who's a 610 kid that shoots the ball
well like the perimeter stretch you know
stretch kind of guy so I'm looking
forward to all of them having an
opportunity to be drafted and I'm gonna
be in the green room and as you know
I'll be physically ill until they're
drafted the two that are in degree move
ten today and then I'll go watch the
rest on the TV and be sick though the
other three okay I was trying to look at
what the what the window of opportunity
it is for these kids to develop where
you get a bit where you get a true sense
of if they're gonna be good NBA players
and the fact that as you mentioned we
got a couple of 18 year-olds in your 19
year olds in here feels like with NFL
draft prospects I look at three years
down the road with NBA I almost have to
look five years down the road to decide
yeah how is that fair right is that a
fair window
you're right yeah and and let me say
this I've had 25 freshmen drafted in the
first round
all 25 freshmen have left us for the
first time we've had 21 lottery picks
all of our kids in the lottery have got
the second contracts and our contracts
or they're not eligible yet but to
really see you gotta wait probably five
years especially if you're thinking
all-star like a Devin Booker in a Karl
towns and some of these guys it was
faster more like three years two years
you know you could tell they're making
it but the normal guy you know most
amendments because they physically have
to mature in football they don't let you
come right out of high school or one
here because fear of death in football
it's a fear of death but in basketball
it's more when are you gonna have funny
is going to start shaving then we can
start judging you know where you are as
a player hard to do that when they're
physically not mature yet what what guy
is in the draft that you went after
didn't get did you go after did you have
a shot at Trey young yeah because he
said he had to call you and tell you
that he's not coming to Kentucky had to
call Bill Self as well yeah and and I've
had that call what do you think I did
after he told me that you know me well
you're gonna do great at Oklahoma and I
wish them well but the the you know
whether state or badly or Carter or we
tried to get involved with all those
kids and so it's you know some kids come
here so kids don't I mean and they're
all really good players and but what I
do know is the kids that left us that
we're a lot
pigs have all made it and then we look
and watch and and my thing with our kids
what happens the greatest thing they
learn with us is how to be a great
teammate yeah you get better playing
against other really good players at
practice every single day but the other
side of this is you have to share how
many players in this draft will be
volume shooters in the NBA
very few just answer for you none zero
so you have to learn to play play off
the ball how many point guards or who
was a point guard in Cleveland who was a
point guard in Golden State ready for
this the best point guard in the league
ended up being off the ball Chris Paul
it harden had the ball so the game is
changing and being a volume shooter and
if our guys are position list they can
play multiple positions that's all
teaching it hopefully getting them ready
and tonight I'll be physically sick
until these guys get fit Congrats have
fun tonight coach always great to check
in with you thanks for joining us and
again keep asking everybody 7-foot or
5-foot because it's a really good
question I guarantee you okay coach you
can look you can say this now and you
can be mocking me but I guarantee you at
some point today you're gonna say
something to somebody about that
question or somebody will walk up to you
and go coach would you rather be 5 feet
tall or 7 feet tall with no athletic
know what I'm probably gonna be stopped
like 5 times I'm going for a walk and I
fully expected so give me some minutes I
may go up to my room and think this
through
yeah so I'm ready to be prepared for
that answer but why don't you ask
Commissioner silver that I'd just be
curious I mean I will okay well I you
know what and then we'll call talk I'll
act I'll ask him and and marked a DeMayo
ask is yeah his you know right-hand man
I'll ask both of them see what they say
when they look at me stupid is there
another follow-up like if they say this
are you stupid stupid if they say that
to me what do I say
just say yeah
okay thanks perfect thank you thank you
culture Thank You coach thank you that's
coach John Calipari for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]